quoi aviez-vous jugé utile d'obtenir la
possibilité d'accéder à tout lieu au
sein de l'assemblée nationale j'ai bien
vu que vous n'aviez pas sollicité cela
pour le sénat ont dit l'acte mais
pourquoi était-il nécessaire que vous
puissiez accéder y compris à l'hémicycle
alors bas -dans à l'intérieur mais juste
à l'entrée
je dispose alors ça peut paraître
complètement voilées réaliste mais sur
la liste ce que j'ai pu dire mais c'est
la réalité depuis que j'ai travaillé au
parti socialiste
j'ai été bénévoles et salariés au parti
socialiste fait les deux j'ai bénéficié
d'un badge d'accès dans ce qu'on appelle
les collaborateurs occasionnels
collaborateurs bénévoles
je citerai pas les noms des deux députés
qu'il nous avait accordée mais quand
vous avez ce type de badges vous avez
accès à la bibliothèque
c'est là où j'ai préparé mes examens de
master et vous avez accès à la salle de
sport que j'ai continuer d'emprunter
quand vous êtes collaborateur du
président la république et vous
sollicitez ce un badge de manière
automatique les services administratifs
de l'assemblée nationale vous délivre un
badge collaborateurs d'emmanuel macron
il est écrit dessus avec un h pour parce
que c'est le plus haut niveau d'accès
mais c'est pas une demande qui a dédié
ses sept nouveaux process automatique
c'est à dire que vous avez le conseiller
politique ou le secrétariat du
conseiller politique qui fait la demande
de badge
je les dis je reconnais c'est un caprice
personnel c'est pourquoi je continue à
la salle de sports la bibliothèque
voilà bon mais il n'y avait pas de
demande particulière avoir accès à toute
l'assemblée
d'ailleurs je sais pas ce que j'aurais
fait dans l'hémicycle ma tête est
inconnu par un certain nombre de
parlementaires jeu